hi there
this is steve kaufman and you are
looking at a personification
of my progress in russian
uh we have introduced this avatar system
at link and
the number of words that i know
determines how big my little guy is he
hatches out of an egg
uh but as i get more and more words he
gets bigger and bigger and then as i
save more words and phrases in other
words as i create more links
i earn credits and i can go and
get them a hat and and clothing and i
got a mabala laika and i got them a
samovar
and in the background i can go and get
our you know cultural icons
so uh yeah i'm really proud of of my
russian guy
i have avatars in all the other
languages that i'm doing but they don't
quite look as good
you'll notice the silver apple
above my head
that means that i've been working quite
hard on my russian if i show you my
spanish or portuguese or korean
first of all they won't have so many
icons and bits of clothing on them and
then the apple might be green or it
might even have a
a worm in it
and that's where we keep track of how
how active people are
so i think this is fun uh i'm doing this
uh video
in uh
jing here i don't know how i get
centered a little bit
just a bit of an experiment here
but uh yeah there's my icon i'm all
excited about my icon so uh
we'll see how this uh this works out
now i'm going to try to save this
uh turn off webcam let's see what
happens
there we go and
mute the microphone no restart no cancel
pause finish